there's trauma in this stress stress is
situational how you know something is
trauma is their response is
disproportionate to the scenario that
suggests that there is a pre-existing
wound Something's Happened before you
came along that's made them
hypersensitive about the situation and
their response is disproportionate so
whenever somebody's response is
disproportionate to the scenario there's
potentially a wound for me personally
all the holistic kind of things don't
necessarily work on me for me the only
way to outdo trauma is to make better
decisions in life your trauma is kind of
going to be always leading you to
self-destructive past your trauma is
going to teach you to live for today and
not worry about tomorrow it's going to
tell you to just indulge but when you
stop and you start valuing yourself and
making good effective decisions you're
going to beat that trauma